según la versión rusa ucrania estaría
preparando una provocación en torno a la
central nuclear de esa polilla fingir
que han sido los rusos los que han
atacado la central nuclear su objetivo
según moscú seguiré a la creación de una
zona de exclusión de 30 kilómetros
alrededor de la central nuclear y
también el despliegue en la zona de una
fuerza internacional desde el gobierno
ruso se ha tachado esta idea como
inaceptable hay que recordar que la
central nuclear de esa policía está en
territorio ucraniano pero está
controlada por los rusos desde el pasado
mes de marzo es la central nuclear más
grande de europa aunque actualmente sólo
uno de los reactores está funcionando y
mientras sigue la tensión en el frente
de moscú ha tomado una decisión de
enviar varios cazas mick con misiles
hipersónicos
el enclave ruso de kaliningrado situado
justo en primera línea con la otan